since we were planning on just going
from Morocco straight to Croatia ended
up packing everything for both trips but
then once we landed we realized hey we
got three hours to kill
let's go home see the kitties eat some
food drop off some Moroccan souvenirs so
we could catch our flight - zombie right
now
my body's used to a different time John
but because there's sunlight outside it
also wants to stay awake but I'm tired
I'm hungry I feel like it's time to - on
the way here my eyes are like bloodshot
red they're better now I think
adrenaline is starting to pump into me
since I'm at the airport but rough
[Music]
all right we are back in it Turkey same
hotel as last time from our honeymoon
coming back or going back you remembered
exactly how to go about the visa when we
got in passport control yeah I remember
yeah because I think it feels just me it
by myself and I can't hear I feel like I
kind of remember this and I'd still be
at the airport at this time
oh thanks to you over here already
comfortable that we always why is that
why is that with the husbands and wives
and it's not just us well your friends
say the same thing all of the wives
my husband's my child can't take care of
yourself anymore you're so dependent on
your wife for that thing that gives us
the purpose deep down every guy as suave
as any guy would ever be or try to put
on there deep down there's just little
boys and little boys my mommies and then
you guys wonder why I don't want to have
any more right now like I go I feel the
same view this is the same room we're
having dinner in our room order room
service cuz a place that they have open
doesn't really have food food they just
have snacks because they told us like if
you want food food you have to order
room service or like oh okay I'll just
get one service because everything else
it's already like 10:00 p.m.
everything else is closed and plus we
don't have Turkish money with us we
don't want to depend on my if
restaurants around are gonna accept
credit cards or not so we're like
do it here and plus we're really tired
we have to wake up in like five hours to
catch our plane I think today was the
first time I ever fell asleep on food oh
it's just unheard of on the plane
they're getting ready to serve it and
just kept trying to wake me up and I was
like no I'm not having it
[Music]
we are in complete zombie mode hopefully
we can get some good rest tonight and
then be in Croatia and have a awesome
seven days in Croatia so we just flew
into Croatia wearing Zagreb it's so
exciting because my dream come true
a tourism board actually hit us up and
wanted us to promote their beautiful
countries of the country of Austria it
was really awesome that the tourism
board even treated us and flew us
business class out here so we had a
pretty comfortable flight and it was
pretty awesome I am pretty tired though
cuz we didn't get that much sleep but
the Adrenaline's pumpin I'm super
excited I can't wait to explore what
Croatia has to offer it looks like our
ride is here
[Music]
nice to meet the DAC genetical so I'm
not invited us out here
we're in istria obviously the three hour
ride here was the most frustrating thing
for me because I was trying so hard to
stay awake to enjoy the view because
it's so beautiful here and I just
couldn't my eyes kept closing and I kept
snoring and I kept waking myself up but
man that was like that was a challenge
trying to stay awake but it's still
gorgeous
[Music]
this is large like Mexicans use it for
everything
pork fat oh yeah how is it buttery
really dirty
so homemade prosciutto ham cooked in
bread underneath of bread ricotta
[Music]
okay I mean I'm never tired of joy
quality want I guess cuz like I've tried
you know the truffle in a mommy right
yeah I don't like it don't like it ya
know cuz there's like a flavor in there
take a lot of battery you ready to
sprinkle some truffle on top
ready the trip did you want to choose
your truffle we'll see if that's enough
Rhodesia
they say well lately
[Music]
oh they're from it's like you would
expect huh no no the only trouble I've
ever had was from a lobby burger I hated
this is actually really good
we go to bed because or you go like that
for you like oh I think I do
mm huh
use your truffle fan out now I know what
it's supposed to taste like
good this is really bad yo you only get
your frickin flowers ready this is like
the best trip ever
my kind of vacation yes feel cheap nice
a fatty tender melts in your mouth
very rich that's the way to do it all
too nice parents
trips from wild pork
right so they brought us la vía leaps
right fine so I'm gonna taste it's Dora
medic it's really fugly better than
potato chip misty this is really good
it's so like Furby evils of an aromatic
you're better than Doritos you have to
try this
nice good this is delicious
who knew a salvia leave or taste so good
one fry like a tempura to cross all good
sorry about wine is getting to us but
this is actually really good now we are
in this super cute boutique hotel look
at the view it's so cute and I could
tell you right now 100% the camera does
not do it just and it smells great it's
like they put Cologne and in the vents
or something it smells really good this
is such a cool trip guys oh my god you
don't know how happy I am right now
thank you guys so much because if it
wasn't for you guys we would not be able
to be here at all so we are all in this
together we're sharing this experience
together so hashtag share is Street cuz
that's all hashtag on this whole trip
anyway yeah I need to take a nap I feel
a little loopy
[Music]
well technically which account yesterday
is day one because we did land at 8:28
and it sounds like a whole day that's
true yeah yesterday was just a nice
little welcome with the wonderful lunch
and then after we had lunch we drove to
this hotel where we are now which is on
the other side of ya across this tree
and so now we're in this hotel called
patella pick tianni so this is where we
are on the mat right there so where we
had lunch was somewhere around here so
we drove across and then once we got to
the hotel we just settled in a little
bit and an hour from when we got to the
hotel we were supposed to have dinner
and so I was like looking at me let me
get a little power nap in it was about
6:00 p.m. at that time and I just
knocked out until this morning I could
not wake up I have never been this
exhausted before because it's usually
especially when we travel I'm constantly
just running on adrenaline like no
matter how tired I am I push through
because I'm like this is awesome I'm
traveling I love traveling so much and
so I just run on the girl adrenaline and
then we've had so many different flights
and like transitioning and when you're
in transition feel like you can't really
like
you're not comfortable you know it's
your Adrenaline's constantly just like
rushing through your system so yeah and
then not only that but especially all
the airline air yeah all the pressure
and like just going like the elevation
and all of that it's it takes a toll on
your body so last night I was like my
body was like nah girl you're done
I've gotta rest so I had to rest and so
are you thank you thank you yeah I need
some coffee
now we're uh we're gonna go have some
adventures explore each Pia
[Music]
you're taking out the lab in town square
this is silver
a dream
so in the first century 2,000 years old
how are they there is a hold olive oil
and wine the ogia wine bottles yeah
we're learning so much history about
11:00 we're gonna go inside
replica of a coal mine so 11 was a coal
mining town if they're gonna go check it
out to see what it was like already but
my head I'm short I know you don't have
to duck down
so this place is actually a replica but
every single item that we see here is
from the real coal mine it is too
dangerous to go to the real coal mine
that's where they created the stuff
without a show the tourists
I like how you're holding your shorts oh
I just put my head again on something oh
man
I'm like I foot eight I'm struggling
here how did tall people get into the
coal mines so they close the coal mines
and lab in the senior L is making these
nice work out
[Music]
like a princess we're gonna be checking
out that area down there it's called my
butt and we're gonna check out the
beautiful beach gonna be so fun it looks
so gorgeous I keep like having to remind
myself that I'm here cuz this place is
so unreal it's so beautiful I feel like
I'm looking at wallpaper everywhere it's
a it's postcard picturesque good sport
he's very romantic yes we need this to
feel romantic it's the icing on top it
is definitely icing it's always good to
have icing this butterfly loves flying
really close I'm like calling like it's
a cat I love how it's flying around like
it's having a great time like it's like
doing sure like not drinks but like like
going with the wind he's giving us a
show he wants some tip tip money late is
that a little bold
so this is the new part of lab in down
there right now we're taking out the old
part down there's like the new part but
it's so cool seeing so many insects
around here but they're not the kind of
insects that you're like oh get away
from me I don't want you near me
these are actually like oh these are
cool take photos we just saw a whole
bunch of butterflies that dragonfly
right there and then that furry
caterpillar it's like out of a fairy
tale I swear even the ants are cool
they're taking the actual seeds located
up cute they're working hard I've never
found insects it's so cute Oh cutie fell
over so exciting I've never tasted olive
oils are never gonna learn how it's
really taste and pick up great olive oil
the first step would be to study and
then we will discuss what you can feel
or understand something okay
to be a polyp oil Somalia's the end of
this I don't know there's so much like
art
[Music]
that's heavy
why because it's bombs do you feel here
yeah something oh yeah it's like spicy
spicy yeah this is from the face is very
important antioxidant molecules this is
the reason why this kind of olive oil
itself excellently this is the reason
why I have thousands of clients they
take everyone in a month spoon of this
olive oil
why because electrolytes politics take
three
[Music]
it's really interesting can taste it
olive oil it's really cool learning
about it so he's saying first you have
to hold it in your hand like this for
about five seconds so you can be like
body temperature and then after you
smell it and what do you smell
you should be smelling like some sort of
citrus but mainly it should smell like
fresh-cut grass and that's how you know
it's good olive oil and then you taste
it and we said it [ __ ] it shouldn't feel
heavy it shouldn't feel really light in
your mouth and your throat should kind
of be a little scratchy and that all of
the antioxidant that is in here so it's
pretty cool
now we're olive oil sommelier and he's
named that a lot of people that come
here and buy a lot of them drink a
teaspoon a day because it's really
healthy you got really a good throw
[Laughter]
[Music]
Cheers
[Music]
really it's really really good it tastes
really fresh really fruity aka
[Music]
plan for you would I feel like this is
all too good for me a desert this is all
good and I'm not even exaggerating like
this is just amazing
queen of the pedigree Jesus so good told
you we're not where to be wash it down
with minutes got to do with the pinky
out
[Music]
you're not supposed to smell it still
moving could at that point while you're
smelling of alcohol but they want to let
it sit then you're able to smell the
actual it'll look great
surely Julie
I couldn't leave without buying one I
had to buy some olive oil this is so
good we're gonna have to like hold on to
it and use it very very sparingly now
we're gonna do a bike tour and a bat
previous video with some electric bikes
and then do this really cool trail and
they're gonna show us a lot of points of
interest and we get to see the ocean and
then after that we get to hang out at
the beach so this is such a dope day we
got some olive tastes my credit and then
beach time is so awesome alright so we
parked our bikes so we can take a look
at this gorgeous view that could sleep
through the trees already wish we could
show you guys footage of the actual bike
trail cuz it was amazing amazing I had
never a mountain bike before so that was
really fun especially with an electric
bike there are a few times where I'm
like oh I'm gonna eat it
let the whales okay there's some pretty
sharp turns around the cliff then this B
keeps following me Jack up each other
baby so beautiful crystal clear
I can't wait to swim in this later
there's a five-star kid hotel here five
stars we're kids I love this I wish she
was here
there's just nothing but kids just
having a blast it makes me miss Isaac
even more all right so we finished our
bike tour and now we are all dressed and
ready for the beach I am so excited cuz
riding by the beach and riding by the
shore and watching everyone just getting
wet and having such a nice time in the
beach I was like I'm so jealous so yeah
now I get to be part of that too we get
to enjoy the nice weather
cuz this weather's perfect it's
literally perfect it's not super hot
it's not that windy it's not cold at all
no what I realized about Croatia is
everything is got architecture got
culinary arts it's got nature it's got
mountains it's got
in Scott Beach Valley everything you
would ever need a temptation spot I wish
I could be a little kid and have my
parents bring me here I'm the kid just
be the parent and the kid that's the
same time oh you can't enjoy the cute
little tiny Lake activities for kids
that they have fun being a kid on could
be pebbles hurt
there's no stand here and someone
there's no sand if you don't get dirty
and when you're if you don't get dirty
nothing gets dirty that's true yeah well
we were up there on the bike I don't
even think it's hard to tell you're in a
beachhead there's no like residual sand
like start sweating and then the white
pebbles just make it look really pretty
and they're so smooth too but it does
kind of hurt to walk on in barefoot when
you're not used to walking on the rocks
oh yeah one thing you pointed out too
was we think that almost every like
section of this Beach is like a private
beach yeah it's so cool here in the back
they have all these like little Bay's or
what would you call it like a face yeah
it's just like it there's a lot of
curves yeah in a lot of curves and again
and again so yeah everyone has their own
private beach you know it's not a
straight shot of beach where you can
just see like rows and rows of people
yeah you don't see a lot of people it
feels very private here true man I
really wish you could have brought the
drone here so beautiful and we could
have showed you guys an aerial view of
all this but no Morocco had to take it
on our way out
[Music]
now we're gonna have never seen pasta
shaped like this my homemade pasta for
this one - yeah this is a traditional
Austrian pasta call for you
[Music]
very positive
that's a nice bite to it kinda nice
texture to it you can see all right the
main course is here and can order a
stick without having some truffle on it
because you know Istria is no further
truffles I guess you can't order it
without trouble because I were in Milan
[Music]
[Music]
I think this is one of the most tender
softest steaks I've ever had in my life
cut her like butter is specifically from
this town of Lebanese and the convicts
got a face I already said so yeah my
mouth right now
[Music]
when to a place is beautiful honestly
all the bids are eventually together I
think this definitely rate the popper
all right day to now we're gonna learn
how to hunt truffles
alright we're going hunting
[Music]